this is crazy breaking movie news batman
this is all so crazy
ah movie posters there's so much
characters
everything we could have hoped for so
much craziness except a trailer
so here's my morning it was up till like
7 00 am
around four after working on some other
stuff i discovered that there's umbrella
academy the latest uploads are getting
blocked they should be live right now so
i had to keep re-editing
fell asleep maybe close to 8am and in
that time bunch of news started dropping
out of my three hours of four hours of
sleep
hey man the moral of the story is go to
sleep more often and we'll get more
movies
jesus so ben affleck is officially
returning as batman
it's official whoa andy muschietti said
it himself we have this article from
vanity fair we're gonna go over
and then we have the batman mad reeves
logo
some artwork from jim lee
let's talk about that super fast because
that won't take long
it looks really cool yeah i immediately
thought of the joker text
that kind of does have that blocky very
uh very stencil on a concrete sort of
look
this is the bat symbol that is on his
chest looks great
i love how film nuari it looks i love
the artwork by jim lee
it looks like a taxidermied bat i reread
the long halloween this feels like a
comic strip from a newspaper with a
gritty edge
yeah you know which is a great i love
that idea
it looks awesome really the whole movie
is red really embodying the red well
there's a pretty sick batman logo
[ __ ] i'm looking at it right now yeah
isn't that bad scary looks like a sick
ass batman it looks like etched on like
[ __ ]
yeah yeah it looks like someone did it
while working out some pent up
aggression
which is what she wants it looks like
you put it on a notepad and it was like
[ __ ] this is it right here it's just
wrong
no it's good it's raw [ __ ] it's his joke
notebook
he just can't help but write really dark
angry symbols in it
can't wait for more out of dc phantom
this saturday let's talk about the ben
affleck stuff now oh boy
i haven't read any of this well get
ready
because it's a pretty juicy piece of
news actually there's so much batman
happening
all right so this comes from andy
muschietti his batman has a dichotomy
that is very strong
which is his masculinity yeah yeah
because of the way he looks in the
imposing figure that he has and his
jawline
yes but he's also very vulnerable hence
his glowing eyes he knows how to deliver
from the inside out that vulnerability
he just needs a story that allows him to
bring that contrast that balance
so affleck got the script at the end of
last week and agreed this
week to join the project this is
crazy yeah this thing that like a week
ago everyone was like now
batfleck's not coming back for anything
my god he's a very substantial part of
the emotional impact of the movie
so is michael keaton and all the other
bad men that will appear
in the interaction emotional frauless
nostalgics the interaction and
relationship between barry and affleck's
wayne
will bring an emotional level that we
haven't seen before
it's barry's movie don't worry guys it's
very it's very story it's still the
flash
well maybe they mean just we haven't
seen barry in a feature film
emote to this degree just because
there's not been that many flash movies
but their characters are more related
than we think
they both lost their mothers to murder
and that's one of the emotional vessels
of this movie
that's where the affleck batman kicks in
oh i can't wait to see a movie about
these heroes bonding over
their mothers and then batman's gonna be
like oh dude tell me about it flash
one time i was fighting superman and he
said martha and i was like
oh and now this is making me feel like
the dc
eu is going to become for moms what
disney princess
movies or disney movies in general are
for dads just like dads always be
dying or always be gone and uh you know
hey i would love to see these two
brooding mama's boys
you know bond and also have to kick some
ass or something
or maybe keaton will step in and smack
some sense into the both of them
we'll see i have some thoughts already
they're coming in he said just you wait
i'm glad to be collaborating someone who
has been on both sides of the camera too
he understands yeah not like bill hader
i think i'm
nailing andy muschietti's tone right now
mushidi said it wouldn't work as well
from intervention to the company of
other batman
without having affleck as the starting
point
he's oh yeah that makes sense because
because
yeah they actually know each other
because barry allen meets bruce wayne in
justice league
and bruce encourages him toward you know
heroism throughout the movie
yeah exactly he kind of does uh he
inspires flash
in justice league so yeah i mean out of
all the batman to
appear in the flash it makes the most
sense
for ben affleck's it's just there's so
many batman now
you know some people might be like it's
just two
two's a lot of batman to be in one flash
movie well yeah especially when you've
already got another batman movie coming
out alongside
that movie he's the baseline he's part
of the
at unaltered state before we jump into
barry's adventure there's a familiarity
there
mushiri goes on to further say this
movie is a bit of a hinge in the sense
that it presents a story that implies a
unified universe where all the cinematic
iterations
that we've seen are val are valid it's
inclusive in the sense that is saying
that all you've seen exist and
everything you will see exist
in the same unified multiverse except
the weeding cut
which we are erasing from the time it's
star wars style
we'll we'll see we'll see actually we
don't know
i mean even zack snyder did say in that
interview with
uh grace randolph from beyond the
trailer if anything
uh the weeding cut might be more
canonically in line with
the current iteration of dcu than his
snyder cut will be okay
oh wow look out retain information
john aye aye sir barbara muschietti
the producer of the flash and sister and
long-time collaborator of the director
and former lover told vanity fair
she had worried this might make him
reluctant to return at all
of course there have been some all sorts
of stories and things he said about
himself having a very hard time playing
batman and it had been difficult for him
i think it was more about a difficult
time in his life
when we approached him he's now in a
very different time in his life he was
very open to it which was a bit of a
surprise to us
it was a question mark in fact we were
just joking
we were just making some jokes and then
he was like yeah i'll do it and you're
like okay ben
he's like no i really want to do it and
please please let me do it i need this
i need to do it please not many people
saw my basketball movie
so now we have to write a whole new
version of the scripture
and here we have the multi-bad verse we
are all human and go through great times
in our terrible uh
our terrible lives great times in our
lives and terrible times in our lives
right now he's in a place where he can
actually enjoy being batman plus he
doesn't have to carry the entire movie
it's a pivotal role but at the same time
it's a fun part she said we know how
much ben affleck likes doing the fun
parts
that's right see that joyce really shine
in the weeding cutter justice league
it it especially yeah i mean his his
face is a whole shade different
i don't not like you i want to see him
in just
like a flat out you know uh adam west
style batman sketch just like if he
does this and and it comes out and snl
is still a thing i want to see him do a
silly bat man just so that we can all
laugh
i'm excited for this man the thing is i
i'm wondering if
they're also going to try to make this
some kind of proper send-off for ben
affleck's batman the thing
is with this new flashpoint movie again
um we're not the first people to say
this and we have said this before
though i'm very excited for it and i am
thrilled at the idea
of michael keaton being in here i am
loving
ben affleck willing to reprise his role
for this
it actually says a lot that ben
affleck's willing to do this
i know we've been making a lot of jokes
on this very serious subject
but at the same time i do got to add
that he seemed very
resistant towards batman and like what
barbara muschietti
um ex-wife to andy muschietti is
saying what barbara muschietti is
stating here
is that he was going through some
personal life things and obstacles and
you know
it sounds like that whole experience
with justice league just
rubbed a lot of the cast members the
wrong way like
life surrounding that whole time was a
little tumultuous for everyone
exactly he seemed like he really wanted
to distance himself from
here with him agreeing to be a part of
this and with andy muschietti it seems
like for the most part
will probably have i mean the flash is a
weird journey and like i can't tell
if andy bushidi will have the creative
freedom he wants to have with this movie
it sounds so strange the amount of
you know um uh delayed development with
this film
however uh right now with its groundwork
with his script
i feel like there must be something
grand here for him to return
it sounds like they're pitching him in a
much more substantial role
than whatever they have in mind for
michael keaton that's
how i mean how this sounds yeah because
no one's come out yet and being like
michael keaton is going to be like a
grandfather to barry and he's gonna
really like
teach him take him under his wing
they're mostly gonna spend time over
dinner talking with each other and
really bonding throughout the movie
you know we haven't heard anything like
that so i feel like he'll be more of a
novelty
now we need to get val kilmer in here
definitely george clooney george
clooney uh kevin conroy kevin conrad
and kellyanne conway and uh and that was
the same
kellyanne conway yeah definitely let's
get will arnett
uh who else has done a batman let's get
the guy from the college humor sketch
where he's finding his voice
yeah it'd be fun this is exciting stuff
i'm i'm very
i'm i'm thrilled at this it's awesome to
be excited for batman and a flashlight
really distracts away from the whole
ezra miller controversy
yeah that's the one thing i am curious
about is like this seems almost like
too good to be true fan news we're
getting a double
dose of bat nostalgia and also we just
can't
seem to address this one little clip of
video but whatever man
well guys we'll see what's in store keep
a lookout for our dc fandom stuff
i will get some sleep for that day what
do you think about ben affleck returning
well stay classy san diego um
keep a look out for all our videos of dc
fandom heck yeah
we'll do like maybe four or five we'll
see
anything um yep i think
i think we're done i think this video is
complete
[Music]